three injured into Southwest Valley
crash you can take a look over my
shoulder here that tow truck just
arrived to pull it out from the building
the white car that you see on that truck
there just moments ago was directly into
the front door of the member Great Cuts
and color that is down here just off
Windmill and Durango it seemingly looks
like the car just went through the front
of the the front door it doesn't look
like any of the surrounding businesses
have any damage or little damages there
is any now we don't have a lot of
information right now from police all
they do report to us at the moment is
that there are three people who were
taken to
UMC for non-life-threatening injuries
were being kept pretty far back I don't
know if you can see from here but police
are not allowing us to go speak to the
different businesses that surround it
now we've called those businesses many
of them have not answered some of them
have answered yet but are just like you
and meek just trying to figure out a bit
more information about what happened
here so we're going to be staying on
site as we get more information from
police about everything leading up to
this crash but for the time being
reporting live here near Durango and
windmill Ryan Matthey 8 News Now